when you invite a woman over to your
house and she says how many women have
you invited here what do you say LOL
California One Stop Shop that's who's
from so how many other women have you
invited here okay so when a woman asks
you how many other women have been here
it's a test she's throwing something out
there to see how you respond okay in my
younger days I would have said something
you know ego I'd have been like
something a little kind of like you're
like I can't I've lost count kind of a
thing you would say that no I'm just
saying I would have said something like
that okay okay just because I would have
wanted like I'm the man I have trickster
all the time
now I know what I've learned I would
probably say something like yeah if you
I can't remember who they are because
I'm more focused on you something a
little
bit
more bang so at the end of the day the
women the woman is asking for two
reasons she just kind of wants to test
you
she wants to know you like how are you
going to respond questions
but then she also wants to feel special
of course so if you can kind of address
it and understand that it's not that
serious of a question you've never dated
that you're not dating this girl she
just kind of wants to know you better
you can play with it but then make her
feel special
but here's the thing if she's already at
your house
and she's asking that you kind of
already know like what she's doing there
I don't really know if like your answer
matters at that point first time at or
your house but like let me uh any girl
that goes to a guy's house and it's like
we don't know what we're doing yet
what are you gonna do at your house okay
well you have to know like something's
gonna go down but okay well there's two
different situations here oh I had 16
girls here you don't want to sleep with
me anymore well it's is it she's at your
house at the beginning of the night or
the end of the night okay because that's
very different well beginning you're
about to go out exactly yeah and I
always recommend if you're gonna go out
take a girl on a date if possible have
her come to your house send her an Uber
have her ballet the car park the car
whatever it is come to your house have a
cocktail get familiar and then go to at
least two to three different spots
because then a girl wants to feel like
she's on a field trip with you all right
great we're gonna go to a bar we're
gonna have a drink then we're gonna go
grab a dinner and then we're gonna go to
an after party next thing you know
you've been to three four different
spots this girl's like she's like he's
resourceful we're going all over we're
having a good time I trust this guy it's
not like he's trying to keep me captive
in his house it's not we go to one place
we go back to the house it's awkward
that's thing you know you've been to
three different spots it feels like a
field trip with this girl her car's at
your house and then it's finally like
hey let's go back to my place so we can
have a night cap or just kind of like
grab your stuff whatever and hey do you
want to come up and then it's just an
easy transition wow so the point is that
I'm getting to is that the beginning of
the night is a lot different from the
end of the night okay but what if you do
like lunch say you're on a lunch date
lunch date
I don't do lunch I'm working tonight
I don't know if I I
could probably count on one hand how
many times I've done a lunch date how
does your lunch dates go I don't do it
like lunch date yeah no sorry not a
lunch date then
I mean I would only do a lunch date if
it's like hey I'm so busy this week I
would only do a lunch date if I'm like
so into the girl and that's like the
only time that she's got time and the
only time I got time lunch date lunch
date
no could you could you bring a girl home
from a lunch date
let's get real here you see what we're
doing right here these drinks it's a lot
easier to get a girl back to your place
if she's got a drink or two when there's
a lunch date and she just ordered the
[ __ ] BLT and she's got to go to work
like unless she's trying to like yo
quickie really quick yeah very very
um not easily done yeah so but it's
doable
sure people do lunch dates and they go
do whatever yeah sometimes they go like
early dinner and then it goes in tonight
and I would totally do that see that's
listen at the end of the day I don't do
lunch you know there's a song out there
that the freaks come out at night right
not to get too freaky here there is
something definitely more sexy fun vibey
about doing it sundown versus 12 o'clock
hot as [ __ ] yeah like sweaty like you're
sweating you're [ __ ] reports doing a
couple hours no that's not hot yeah it's
true you know that is very true lunch is
not hot dinner's hot so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]